are so many things to look forward to
during the holiday season one of those
decorations but it's important to keep
safety top of Mind whether you're
putting them up yourself or hiring
someone Madison Kimbrough joins us from
one of the more lit neighborhoods in the
valley near Harmon and Spencer with the
details
this neighborhood here in the Central
Valley has made it its mission to
decorate many of these neighbors doing
it all themselves but with all this work
safety comes in mind I didn't just do
the lights by myself I did it with my
family it's getting lit for the holiday
season and with so many across the
valley decorating their homes inside and
out decorating safety is key we and
several others couldn't help but notice
this neighborhood in the Central Valley
all lit up for the holiday season
homeowner Ken Frizzell says when it's
time to decorate he always makes sure to
have his family watching nearby I'd
never get up on a roof alone I always
have either my wife or or one of my boys
that get up with me James Hanley with
the happy holiday lighting company in
Vegas shares some do's and don'ts when
it comes to decorating I'll see people
just random people in the neighborhood
installing with tennis shoes on and
that's extremely dangerous one of the
biggest issues is people step on the top
of the ladder then on the home and the
ladder kicks out so that's where a
spotter is very important Las Vegas has
been lightened up it it's been a great
Christmas we've seen a huge demand this
year also make sure you're using the
correct ladder for the job is it tall
enough so you can reach what you're
doing and make sure to use a ladder that
can hold not only your weight but your
tools and the decorations you're hanging
when in doubt hiring professional help
is always the best solution especially
if Heights are involved with the locals
we spoke to many say even with the high
energy costs decorating with lights is a
must for their family especially since
it brings a lot of joy to them and those
driving by reporting near Spencer and
Harmon Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now